la escala en un mapa es 7 centímetros a
10 kilómetros o sea cada 7 centímetros
son 10 kilómetros si la distancia entre
dos ciudades es de 60 kilómetros desde
la distancia real que están separadas en
centímetros están estas dos ciudades en
el mapa bueno pues nos dan la escala
verdad nos dicen que 10 kilómetros 10
kilómetros
son siete centímetros son siete
centímetros por cada siete centímetros
tenemos diez kilómetros o viceversa pero
nos dan también la distancia entre
ciudades entonces esto lo podemos pensar
así
aquí tenemos diez kilómetros aquí le
vamos a poner 60 kilómetros pero para
pasar de aquí a acá multiplicamos por 6
aquí multiplicamos por 6 entonces para
no alterar la proporción el numerador
también tenemos que multiplicarlo por 6
y de esta forma 10 kilómetros en la vida
real son 7 centímetros y así 60
kilómetros son 6 por 7 o sea 42
centímetros así que que están separadas
en centímetros están estas dos ciudades
en el mapa pues 42 centímetros